[Aplausos]
[Música]
existem muitas formas de assédio existe
o assédio moral que é aquele que ocorre
geralmente no ambiente de trabalho onde
tem uma hierarquia ea pessoa fica numa
posição superior se aproveita do
empregado torturando ou tirando vantagem
ou permitindo que alguém faça existe o
assédio psicológico que também é
considerado assédio moral que funciona
como um comportamento e penitente de
terror ameaça pânico para causar
preocupação pra confundir a autoestima
do assediado e existe o assédio sexual
que é basicamente qualquer forma de
avanço sexual não consensual qualquer
forma de constrangimento com o objetivo
de tirar obter vantagem sexual sobre uma
pessoa
todos esses tipos de assédio tem um
monte de ramificação subdivisões
inclusive do ponto de vista legal mas
meu foco que hoje é o assédio sexual o
assédio sexual em suas mais variadas
formas baguaçu vio ao estupro e no caso
do brasil atinge mais de 80% das
mulheres segundo uma pesquisa do
instituto yougov divulgada em 2016
nessa pesquisa foram entrevistadas 500 e
três mulheres
mais de 80% delas disseram que sofreram
assédio sexual ajude 77% a subir 57
comentários de cunho sexual 47% olhares
instantes 44% já tiveram seus corpos
tocados 39% já foram xingados 37% já
tiveram um homem se exibindo para elas e
oito por cento já foram estupradas em
locais públicos
uma outra pesquisa realizada pelo blog
fim que olga pela campanha chega de fio
que era contra o assédio dos espaços
públicos de 7766
mulheres ou sete mil setecentos e
sessenta e duas mulheres 99,6 por cento
já sofreram assédio em locais públicos
aí existe um pensamento é apaziguador
que tenta colocar o assédio sexual de
forma ponderada e afirma que dois essas
formas constrangimento aqui citadas não
só o assédio sexual mas é um equívoco
primeiro porque quem define será sede ou
não é a vítima e no caso dessa pesquisa
do fim que olga por exemplo todas as
mulheres disseram a mesma coisa e uma
das conclusões mais significativa que
chegaram é justamente de que as mulheres
têm um medo real de caminhar nas ruas
o medo real de andar por aí livremente
simplesmente pelo fato de serem mulheres
então não tem como dizer o que é ou não
a set partindo do princípio que você não
é vítima isso é muito complicado ver o
que acontece
o assédio sexual e está muito pra lei
infelizmente do que essas pesquisas
alcançam e ele também não está presente
só nos espaços públicos está presente
nas casas nas instituições de ensino nas
instituições religiosas nas organizações
religiosas de uma forma geral nas
empresas em todas as classes sociais e
de onde vem a banalização do assédio vem
da naturalização da objetificação do
corpo da mulher o que assim o que
significa isso muito simples
todas essas imagens que eu vou mostrar
pra vocês são imagens totalmente
naturalizados que a gente está
acostumado a lidar no nosso cotidiano
em todas elas o corpo das mulheres são
apresentados de forma sexual comercial
o fato da gente naturalizar tantas
imagens quanto fato da gente naturalizar
o assédio sexual nas ruas o assédio
sexual de uma forma geral vem de uma
construção de pensamento uma construção
cultural de dominação masculina
um exemplo dessa dominação masculina é
que essas imagens pra nós são muito
normais totalmente naturais ea gente
um lado a lidar com elas ao longo da
nossa vida já essas aqui seria
impossível dizem ver né
o que acontece é a dominação masculina
ela não atinge somente as mulheres
ela atinge os homens também a gente
pensa o tipo ideal masculino a gente
percebe que essa iluminação não é justa
com ninguém mas essa dominação masculina
ela não diz respeito à individualidade
masculina de cada homem
ela diz respeito à masculinidade
soberana na sociedade
e aí quando ela impõe esse modelo que as
mulheres devem seguir ou esse modelo que
os homens devem tratar as mulheres a um
ponto também comportamento dos homens
seja mais que seja forte seja eu não
demonstra emoção não chorar em público
só pode expressar o único sentimento é a
raiva seja duro seja atlético caso das
mulheres como objeto dessa dominação
como eu disse não é justo pra ninguém
mas acontece que é muito cara para nós
mulheres
todos os dias as mulheres saem na rua
todos os dias elas saem conhecimento que
os brasileiros expuseram nas pesquisas
que mostrei pra vocês mas nós não
estamos é no momento num momento pior
desse contexto e do assédio sexual
acho que a gente está num ótimo momento
para discutir inclusive a liberdade de
vida às mulheres nos últimos anos muitos
movimentos de mulheres têm surgido
muitas frentes estão sendo organizados
as primaveras as mulheres pelo mundo
as hashtags meu amigo secreto meu
primeiro assédio no brasil é os casos de
assédio envolvendo atores e produtores
de hollywood estão cada vez mais sem
respostas
os casos de assédio em locais públicos
que estão tomando proporções globais
tudo isso são exemplo de que agora a
gente tá começando a discutir um
comportamento que era tido como padrão e
que agora já não estava sendo visto
dessa forma tão velada é num 2002 nenhum
12 edições do cineclube cinema pago que
a gente fez a gente realiza em
petrópolis a gente exibe o filme
precisamos falar do assédio
e aí esse filme reúne uma porção de
depoimentos de mulheres brasileiras de
classes sociais endereços cores
diferentes um ponto em comum todas elas
sofreram histórias sérias de abusos e
violências e assédio sexual
depois do filme a gente fez um debate e
uma coisa que me chamou muita atenção me
impressionou muito
foi o depoimento de uma moça que disse
que ali naquele momento assistindo filme
ela percebeu que ela viveu uma violência
durante anos a vida dela que não sabia
que ela tinha vivido
aos 12 anos ela foi obrigada pela mãe a
se casar com um homem 13 anos mais velho
que só agora com 28 anos ela precisou
ver esse filme para perceber o tamanho
da violência que ela tinha sofrido o que
me faz pensar em algumas coisas
primeiro no tanto que a gente precisa
avançar no brasil em relação ao resto do
mundo porque assim no resto do mundo têm
soluções legais sendo pensadas para esse
tipo de violência sexual
aqui no brasil as coisas não caminham
passos leite simus né
por exemplo se um ator famoso de uma
série famosa do netflix envolvido em
casos de assédio ele é automaticamente
afastado ea série automaticamente
retirado do ar
um ator famoso brasileiro da maior
emissora televisiva do país
quando passa pelo mesmo caso além da
situação se lidado com extrema
naturalidade e não sofre na prática
conseqüência nenhum as leis no brasil
são insuficientes
é e aí pra trazer um exemplo bem claro é
bem recente é só a gente lembrar nesse
caso de assédio ocorreu um transporte
público recentemente em que o assediador
que já tinha levado várias ocorrências
da polícia por conta do mesmo problema
ele foi liberado porque não existe na
constituição brasileira algo que consigo
incriminar essa pessoa porque é que não
existe porque para ele ser acusado com
violência sexual o assédio sexual sem é
preciso que configurasse conjunto
um canal e olha que nesse caso o
assediador ejaculou lídima sul também
chocante né
esse momento dessa sessão do cinema
bagulho precisamos falar do assédio
me lembrou justamente essa primavera das
mulheres esse momento de quebra de
paradigmas
esse lugar agora a história que a gente
está vivendo que a gente precisa se unir
a gente possa construir espaços para as
mulheres que a gente precisa pesar
sobretudo a união de todas as pessoas
e aí eu quero convocar os homens que
ocupam cargos públicos precisamos pensar
em leis que defendam a liberdade das
mulheres precisamos pensar em políticas
públicas para as mulheres e os amigos do
direito e os grandes empresários quanto
os cargos de relevância as mulheres
ocupam nas suas empresas eo mapeamento
de violência de gênero nosso país no
mundo e o lamento da violência contra a
mulher na nossa cidade que tem números
alarmantes
a gente precisa sobretudo compreender
que em ponto os direitos básicos das
mulheres como a liberdade de ir e vir é
um direito civil não for garantido
a gente está longe de um estado
democrático
a gente está longe de pé de igualdade
a gente está longe de qualquer igualdade
entre os seres humanos
obrigada gente boa tarde
[Aplausos]